[Musik]
sebastian zeigt dass in fertigen
sandwiches von der tankstelle steckt
dafür klebt er einen schinken aus hinten
brust zusammen und baktus brot wie die
industrie mit ein paar genialen tricksen
die belegten brote am ende wochen lang
haltbar
kennen sie das noch das pausenbrot nach
der sechsten stunde
das war nicht wirklich mehr lecker oder
die lebensmittelindustrie die hat es
geschafft ein sandwich über eine woche
haltbar zu halten
mal gucken was da so drin steckt aber
voller licht sieht man schon wie die
salze vom käse
das brot langsam auflösen
sieht nicht appetitlich aus ist aber
auch nach tagen in der verpackung
bedenkenlos genießbar dahinter steckt
clevere entwicklungsarbeit der
lebensmittelindustrie relativ viele
essiggurken teure produkte haben eine
unendliche haltbarkeit mikroorganismen
mögen keine säure ein hühnerbrust
sandwich soll saftig gut belegt und
trotzdem schön günstig sein hühnerbrust
ist aber unförmig und teuer
sebastian lege will darum einzelne
fleischstücke zu einer art schinken
zusammenkleben ein bisschen salz
phosphat schluck wasser dazu und den
rest macht jetzt meiner maschine der
sogenannte tumblr funktioniert wie eine
waschmaschine mit unter druck durch das
ständige rotieren nehmen die proteine im
fleisch mehr wasser auf der unter druck
lässt wasser und phosphat noch tiefer
eindringen
das fleisch wird schwerer und
gleichzeitig weich und klebrig
[Musik]
sieht schön schleimig aus machen wir aus
druck ablassen die masse ist jetzt
voller wasser und sehr gut formbar so
gut aus damit in die presse über nacht
sollen sich die fleischbrocken im
kühlschrank zu einem viereckigen stück
verbinden aufgeschnitten ergibt das
später immer gleiche sandwich scheiben
bis es soweit ist kümmert sich sebastian
lege um toastbrot für sein haltbares
sandwich
in düsseldorf ist er mit bäckermeister
michael dort verabredet seine backstube
ist berühmt für ihren traditionellen
tost hergestellt mit besten mail jeder
menge butter und selbst gezüchteten
sauerteig
michael bauer hat hat sich
traditionelles backhandwerk auf die
fahnen geschrieben
becker tost sauerteig bei ihm die alles
entscheidende zutat die über lockerheit
geschmack und haltbarkeit bestimmt seine
handwerks methode braucht allerdings
viel zeit
[Musik]
das duo aus kanada danach reingehauen
oh ja es fühlt sich sehr gut an doch vor
dem backen muss der teig noch stunden
lang ruhen und später sind die brote
nicht sehr lange haltbar
[Musik]
in scheiben schneiden
belege und dann ins thüringer stelle wie
lange wäre es haltbar
drei tage ich muss aber ein toastbrot
machen was zwei wochen haltbar ist
wer guckt auf seine zusätzliche so
geht's nicht
sebastian liege zeigt wie ein industrie
tost haltbar wird dazu braucht er neben
wasser mehl hefe und salz nur eine
einzige spezial zutaten ab zitat natrium
azetat ist ein farbloses leicht saures
salz der essigsäure die zutat senkt den
ph wert und macht dadurch lebensmittel
länger haltbar
natrium azetat steckt in mayonnaise und
salatdressings in feinkostsalaten und in
praktisch jedem toastbrot auf dem
supermarkt
ganz wichtig dass nach dem zitat ist
halt die säure die dafür sorgt dass ist
brot nicht schon mit
damit der toast nicht nur haltbar
sondern auch billig wird verwendet
sebastian lege statt teurer butter
billiges pflanzenöl und künstlich
hergestelltes butter aroma
außerdem nutzt er hefe stadt sauerteig
das spart stundenlange teig ruhe und
senkt die produktionskosten noch weiter
[Musik]
also ich würd sagen fasst man das hat
schon mal geglaubt das hat schon mal
geklappt
ich bin eben sehr skeptisch mit mit dem
ganzen das ist butter roma war jetzt
auch in der ganzen bäckereien unterwegs
butter aroma ist günstig und hat noch
einen weiteren vorteil aroma kann nicht
ranzig werden
auch das ist ein grund warum sein
einsatz in allen bereichen der
lebensmittelindustrie seit jahren
zunimmt
wie lange muss dass banken 40 5 40
minuten
sebastian läge es billiger industrie
tost was sagt bäckermeister gauer dazu
[Musik]
hier bitteschön kleine stück möchte ich
ja nie vergessen
[Musik]
sebastian ist ein super tost wer hätte
ich nicht erwartet
er ist auch vielleicht nicht ganz mein
geschmack natürlich es muss ein bisschen
wenig ich glaube weil wir ein bisschen
viel aroma rein gemacht haben vielleicht
und wie schmeckt dagegen der mit viel
zeit und besten zutaten hergestellte
beckert
[Musik]
du das kläppchen ja klar
klar das knöpfchen soll das für dich
danke ich schneide mir eine andere
scheinbar man riecht auf jeden fall den
sauerteig 100pro geschmacklich super
charakteristisch da hat er natürlich
handwerk par excellence zelebriert
tolerant kraft cook kein gutes brot sie
ist ja auch hier geht es dir auf zack
springen wieder zurück packe ich das
zusammen
daran erkennt man gute backwaren jetzt
mal gleich hier meine beine hände
ich drücke drauf und der kollege zac der
steht wieder auf den kann es immer
wieder eine geben
wir stehen immer wieder auf wie ein
preisboxer sebastian läge es billig tost
kann eindeutig nicht mit der qualität
von handwerksbäcker mithalten
dafür ist es deutlich länger haltbar
dank natrium azetat dass in allen
gängigen tost marken in deutschland
enthalten ist und in fertig sandwiches
sowieso
zurück zum bella dem sebastian lege aus
hühnerbrust stücken zusammengeklebt hat
nach einer nach dem kühlschrank kommt
jetzt der moment der wahrheit hält die
masse zusammen klappt wunderbar
aneinander binden reicht warum ihren
dämpfen runterkühlen scheiben schneiden
und genüsslich in sandwich beißt bei
kochschinken ist diese methode vor
einigen jahren unter verbrauchern in
verruf geraten
doch das zusammenfügen von fleischresten
findet nach wie vor statt
verbraucher haben es nicht leicht das zu
erkennen
hersteller verstecken die unbequeme
wahrheit lieber im kleingedruckten aus
putenbrust stücken zusammengefügt so
heißt die methode offiziell
nun ist auch sebastian legis
klebefleisch soweit nach dem
aufschneiden ist es nicht mehr von ganz
normalem schinken zu unterscheiden
wie lecker aus schmeckt das auch super
und auch schön trocken
die cremigkeit für sandwich dafür machen
wir jetzt die soße die sieht in vielen
fällen zwar aus wie mayonnaise hat in
wirklichkeit aber nichts damit zu tun
rohe eier und lange haltbarkeit passen
einfach nicht zusammen
kleiner tipp für zuhause man brauche
nicht immer ein gelb damit man eine
mayonnaise artige soße erzeugt deswegen
machen wir jetzt eine vegane mario hohes
gefäß bisschen sojamilch pürierstab
gehen braucht man dafür wirklich weil
ohne das würde die illusion gar nicht
funktionieren illusionen wasser und fett
tröpfchen vereinen sich miteinander und
ergeben daher durch eine homogene soße
also schön aufschreibt und ganz dünn
das ölreiche stadt mit sojamilch
funktioniert dieses rezept auch mit ganz
normaler h milch
das resultat ist den beiden fällen eine
perfekte wochen lang haltbare creme die
sich ganz nach wunsch ab schmecken lässt
und jetzt ist auch ganz wichtig dass wir
die poren von dem brot mit dem fett
komplett zu sperren weil wir wollen eine
isolationsschicht schaffen damit die
anderen zutaten die leicht ausbessern
können von der creme umschlossen werden
damit es halt nicht gangelt
dünn geschnittene essiggurken halten
mikroorganismen vom wachsen ab aus sicht
der industrie ist selbst das belegen von
sandwich eine wissenschaft für sich
alles nur damit bloß nicht schimmelt
und fertig ist unser sandwich für das
kühlregal probiert mal um das ganze ist
noch mehrere wochen haltbar
guten appetit angst dass dieses sandwich
schlecht wird muss man als verbraucher
also erstmal nicht haben doch die
industrie hat mit zahlreichen tricks
kosten gesenkt und die haltbarkeit
erhöht wie gesund sind solche
industrieprodukte dann eigentlich noch
wenn es mal schnell gehen soll in der
mittagspause und man wirklich überhaupt
keine andere möglichkeit hat dann kann
man das mal essen ob es dann ein genuss
ist natürlich die frage je nachdem
welches andrews ist war von den
inhaltsstoffen her sollte man das aber
wirklich nicht zu oft machen die lange
haltbarkeit an sich macht diese
lebensmittel nicht ungesund
die ursache sind pfiffige verfahren die
die industrie für jeden
herstellungsschritte entwickelt hat
gleichzeitig wird bei fertigen
sandwiches zu oft an teuren zutaten
gespart und das geht in vielen fällen
zulasten der qualität
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was kommt alles auf euer lieblings
sandwich sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips